how does the person become the person
they are
and why do they keep their health
condition the same and well
most people your brain is a record of
the past it's an artifact fact of
everything you've learned and
experienced at this moment so most
people wake up in the morning if you
think that your thoughts have something
to do with your destiny they start
thinking about their problems and those
problems are just memories that are
etched in their brain that are connected
to certain people and objects and
certain things at certain times and
places and the moment they start
thinking about their problems they're
thinking in the past now because every
one of those problems has an emotion
associated with them
the moment they start feeling unhappy or
feeling sad now their body's in the past
because thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings are the language of
the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being though
the problem is is that the person thinks
of the problem feels the emotion and
that is a thought and feeling that's a
image and an emotion it's a stimulus and
response and that starts the
conditioning process to get the body
emotionally conditioned into the past
now here's the crazy part about it yes
the familiar past
emotionally
is producing dramatic effects on the
body because the body is so objective
that it does not know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion and the emotion
that person is fabricating by thought or
memory alone the body's believing it's
living in the same past experience
seven days a week 365 days a year and
the problem with that is is that the
environment signals the gene that's
epigenetics and the end product of an
experience and the environment there's
an emotion so the person is keeping the
same gene regulated because the body's
believing it's living in the same
environmental condition so
getting that person to step outside of
that familiar known territory into the
unknown
where there is uncertainty and have them
be comfortable there and begin to think
about how they are going to think
need motivation watch a top 10 video
with believe nation hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best dr joe dispenza and my take
on his top 10 rule to success enjoy
rule number two feel gratitude the new
model of reality is about causing an
effect
that means then you have to feel
gratitude every day for your new
experience to occur
you can't wait for your success to feel
empowered
you have to be empowered to create the
success
and when you teach people how to do this
and they move into a new state of being
they begin to create the life that they
want
how many people are still with me
but to the materialists they would say
well no
no no no i'm going to wait for my money
to come and then i'm going to give
thanks
and those people pretty much are living
by the emotions of the past
and if you're living by the emotions of
the past you were viewing your future
through the lens of the past and your
vision will fade
because when you bring up an elevated
emotion you will see the vision clearly
and leaders in history that changed the
world knew how to change a culture look
at martin luther king
he talked about justice and then got
enough people inspired
that they felt empowered enough to do
something about it
people came out of the resting state
and so then you share the same brain as
martin luther king
and being defined by a vision of the
future begins to change a culture
but most people have the same thoughts
or the same intentions and they live by
the same familiar emotions and for the
most part they're in their past rule
number three change your energy love
inspires us
it inspires us to give
it inspires us to express it inspires us
to serve
to care for one another to be kind to
one another uh to listen with compassion
and understanding
and love actually causes us to
create we become creative in that state
and you've heard me say
that when there is a change in energy
there's a change in your life and and
inspiration is a change in energy
and if you don't change your energy if
you stay in the same energy
then it makes sense that your life stays
the same
so if you can
become inspired
and raise your energy
you become aware of things that you were
once unaware of why because
energy causes us to become conscious of
things we are once unconscious to in
other words you change your frequency
you have more access
to information and that's the name of
the game here so
if you stay at the same level of energy
every single day then you will be
unaware of possibilities you'll you'll
not be able to create anything new
so you can't see any possibilities again
from the same energy
in order for you to become inspired by
love inspired by energy you'll become
conscious of possibilities that you were
once unconscious of
now
energy
or energy and motion
their emotions and so if
we live by the same emotions every
single day
and we haven't changed who we are
and there's a movement happening or
you're in the creative state
and you stay in the same feelings and
the same familiar emotions
then you can't see any possibilities
because you're looking through the lens
of some past experience
and you can only see the same
so then
inspiration then
the word inspiration means
the movement of energy
inspiration to inspire in spirit it is
becoming more energy and less matter
rule number four make a difference the
future then is created by a clear
intention and an elevated emotion now
listen closely
that you have to cultivate in your inner
environment of thoughts and feelings
but most people
by the old self are living from past
memories that are created from knowledge
and experience from something that
happened outside of them
some experience or trauma that defined
them and getting a person beyond the old
self then
is the great work that's what we're here
for
so
we've studied motivation
and i can tell you without a doubt
that the highest form of motivation
in any culture
in any group of people
is what's called purpose motivation
duty motivation or mission motivation
you know what that is
to have a vision to change a culture
that's bigger than you
to instill change in the world
look at elon musk how many people know
who he is
elon musk he created tesla motors
you know him
you know who he is
he created an electric car
that can go from zero to 60
in less than five seconds
and before him electric cars were like
golf carts
that cr you know crawled along the road
and he said
i'm gonna do this i don't know how i'm
gonna do it but i have a vision
and i'm going to get the best engineers
in the world
and instead of creating a new product
and selling it to a corporation
i'm going to get a group of people to
share the same vision as me
i'm going to change the world by
changing our reliance on oil
and i'm going to make a difference in
the world and i am going to make a lot
of money
why not
and so people said no that's not
possible and he held on to that vision
and now motor trend magazine
never raided a car uh close to a hundred
they raided the tesla car 103.
it's the best car on the road
and it relies on no gas at all that's a
vision of the future
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five make different choices
i got run over by a truck and and and i
broke six vertebrae in my spine
and i had to make a decision at that
time in my life um
because the diagnosis wasn't very good
and neither was the prognosis and
to decide if i was going to spend the
rest of my life on addictive medications
and with surgical rods in my spine or if
i was going to see if the mind could
actually heal the body and so that was
my wake-up call uh in 1986 and so so i
just um
i was at the point where i just had to
make a decision to see if it was
actually the truth if if all of this
that i learned was the truth let's let's
apply it and so i was lucky enough to
have a dramatic change in my own
personal health and then i thought god
if it worked on me as it worked on other
people so i started looking into people
that had you know been treating
conventionally or non-conventionally and
and with a certain diagnosis
and their condition was staying the same
getting worse and all of a sudden it got
better and and i just wanted to
look at what the cause was that was
producing that effect and so i
interviewed you know hundreds and
hundreds of people that had gone through
the process
and one of the most fundamental elements
that they all had in common with there
were a lot of things that had to do with
their mind and
uh and some people had specific diets
and specific regimes some people use
certain um you know conventional
non-conventional protocols but the the
commonality primarily was about how the
mind was really influencing the body and
and
they began to really take a closer look
at how
they were thinking
on a daily basis uh how they were acting
uh on a regular basis and looking at how
they feel
on a moment-to-moment basis and
and how you think and how you act and
how you feel is your personality and
your personality has a very direct
relationship with your personal reality
which means if you want to change your
personal reality if you want to change
something about your life you got to
change and so the process of change then
becomes the fundamental process of going
from some person that's familiar and
known to you and stepping out and
beginning to make different choices and
to begin think different thinking
differently and being to behave
differently and speak differently and
feel differently and
and if you start thinking acting and
feeling differently our research shows
without a doubt
you're going to have dramatic changes in
your biology and if you do it enough
times you're going to become someone
else and the disease then all of a
sudden exists in the old personality
and not in the new personality and then
you ask the person where's the cancer
where's the rheumatoid arthritis where's
the immune mediated condition uh it's in
the old person i'm not that person any
longer rule number six have a clear
intention if you have been an
experienced
uh if you had experience of trauma say
for example and it's created the feeling
of fear and your fear is that it could
happen again
and you're you don't know this but every
time you think about that future that
possible worst case scenario scenario
and you feel the emotion you're
conditioning your body to become the
mind subconsciously of anxiety
so now
all you need now is some cue in your
outer environment that says it's unsafe
that if there's damage there that you're
you're a victim something's bigger than
you that could have an effect on you
well now
that feeling of fear
is going to cause you to think thoughts
equal to it
so the person then
no longer needs the environment
to feel that fear they just have to have
the thought about
that condition now and now
they're literally knocking their brain
and body out of balance by thought alone
and the body's constantly living in
emergency mode and it takes a lot of
energy
a lot of resources to live in emergency
mode all the time
guess what system becomes compromised by
the immune system your immune system why
because you have two protection systems
you gotta you have a system that
protects you from dangers in your outer
world that's that's the gas pedal that's
the sympathetic nervous system that's a
fight-or-flight nervous system danger
threat out there use all the energy
because you gotta you gotta survive and
when you survive you gotta take care of
your body so right so so now
that system can work really well short
term
it doesn't work really well if you keep
it on all the time because if you're
mobilizing all that energy for some
threat in your outer world there's no
energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building projects and energy
leaves the brain and it leaves the heart
and it moves into these lower centers
because now you're tapping the body's
resources because there is an emergency
but whether the emergency is real or
imagined
whether your anger is valid or justified
or not
that the you're tapping the body's very
energy to heal by doing this and the
immune system says
well we're part of really the other
nervous system we're the break we're the
clutch we need the we need to get into
relaxation we need to get back into
balance again and when we do then we'll
metabolize then we'll we'll assimilate
we'll reproduce we'll
excrete properly
so
so now you got this kind of battle
between the gas pedal and the brake and
the immune system says hey listen if
there's foreign agents if there's
viruses bacteria molds funguses listen
we don't have a whole lot of energy here
to deal with them because we're fighting
this war out there there's no homeland
security so they shut down
certain receptors in the immune system
they shut down function
of those lymphocytes those white blood
cells that are your inner army of
protection and it takes a lot of energy
to fight a virus in a bacteria but if
there's no energy hey listen it takes
energy to raise the body's temperature
where do you think that comes from
that's part of that branch called the
autonomic nervous system and the
sympathetic the gas pedal is part of it
and the parasympathetic is the clutch is
part of that autonomic nervous system
and it's a check and balance let's talk
about the neuroscience of culture
because there is a neuroscience to it
you have a brain that looks just like
the person sitting next to you
and if i was to screw off the top of
your heads
and take out your brain and your
partner's brain someone sitting next to
you and i went like this
and i set them out you probably wouldn't
be able to tell them apart
because you share the same structure in
your brain
and we call that universal traits and we
call it gross anatomy
now
because you share the same brain as the
person sitting next to you you smile
when you're happy
you frown when you're sad you sleep at
night well this is mexico you sleep
kinda late at night and get up kinda
late in the morning
come on i'm kidding
and you know you grab a stick the same
way we speak a language and because we
share the same gross anatomy of the
brain we have very universal traits that
we have in common how many people are
with me
but now
how your brain is wired
is your individuality
and that's the minut architecture or the
minute structure of the brain
so then
your brain is wired different than the
person next to you because you have
different experiences but if you share
the same experiences because you're in a
relationship then you have similar
brains that are kind of relating and
relationships are built on common
experiences if we share the same
experiences we share the same emotions
and if we share the same emotions we can
relate with each other
so then think about it like this
you have a hand
and because you have a hand you you have
the same hand as the person next to you
there's only a certain amount of things
you can do with your hand
but now
what makes you unique
is your fingerprint that gives you your
individuality and that is really the
minute anatomy
of something related to a hand are you
with me
so now what is the division that unifies
both the universal traits
and our individual traits
and the answer is
culture
culture
and culture is defined by the
environment in which you live
the environment in which you work
the environment of your family
an environment is made up of just a few
things are you ready
people objects things places
time pets
and that's pretty much your environment
so the culture of mexico city
is defined by the environment
you eat certain foods you like certain
music
you relate with one another because of
the environment in which you live in
and that culture is created from the
environment which is different than the
culture of mongolia
because it's a different environment and
they have different traditions they have
different customs because they've had to
survive in a different environment
and so what unifies individual
individual traits and universal traits
is called culture now think about this
most cultures are defined by the customs
they have the traditions the language
their survival skills their habits their
attitudes their beliefs their history
their arts their social structures that
have unified them as an individual
culture
are you still with me
so the people you work with
the people you relate with the people
you interact with you share a similar
culture that bonds you both as an
individual and as a species called human
beings
and mexicans are different than
australians because they live in a
different environment and they have
different traditions
you still with me but we could say then
that culture typically is defined by
things that have worked in the past
so then
most cultures then
have a choice
to create a new culture means then you
have to define your culture as a vision
of the future
but most people
their cultures are based on the past
present reality what does that mean we
are in a changing world
and the world is changing faster than
most people can keep up and if you are
going to stay defined by a memory of the
past you will not keep up with this
culture because we are creating a global
culture
so then
what
defines the vision of the future to
change a culture
and the answer is a very clear intention
a clear purpose
combined with an elevated emotion
and when you combine a clear intention
like a vision of the future
along with an elevated emotion of
inspiration and joy you will create an
empowered individual rule number seven
create what you want what's something
that you've said in the past that you
were confident about it then but now
upon reflection you're like oh i should
have changed my mind about that oh that
it takes a long time to create reality
i'm going to ask you to expand on that
because i like that answer i want to
know more that's fascinating
well um i think just like anything else
uh you learn how to snowboard you go
through that learning curve you learn
how to ride a bike you go through that
learning curve
uh that that i used to think that
creation was hard
i just thought it took a lot of energy
and it took a lot of sacrifice and it'll
work for it and great and uh god i mean
even my definition of surrender
today is very different than it was just
three months ago because i'm always
doing it
and so
i think that
it doesn't have to be that way i just
think that it could be any way you want
and that and then working on that
changing that belief rule number eight
be a self-starter personal conviction
motivation
we call these people self-starters this
is entrepreneurial motivation
this is when you say
i'm to do this because i said i was
going to do it
still a high form of motivation but not
the highest form
but what we know
that people who have purpose motivation
naturally are personally convicted
their their personal conviction is in
alignment with their purpose
because they have a reason to get up
every day rule number nine initiate
learning if someone is so
disconnected to their future their
greater future self if they're so
uh
negative thoughts suicidal thoughts
often
hurting themselves potentially often
what can they start to do to just give
some a little bit of relief and peace in
their heart yeah it's simple knowledge
experience wisdom
philosophy initiate that philosophy
master it yep mind body soul
thinking
doing being learning with your head
applying it with your hands knowing it
by heart
and this is the journey of knowledge
because when you learn that information
and you really study it you are going to
begin to see the world differently
because your brain is changing then when
you start saying how can i use this how
can i apply it how can i personalize it
how can i do something initiate this
information what am i going to do how do
i get my behaviors to match my
intentions now this is the act of trial
and error it's so important you don't
make it the first time you don't give up
you get up and you try to walk again
and you start learning how to do this
and so as you begin to do it over and
over again you start having new
experiences yes well new experiences
enrich the circuits in your brain
philosophically and now the brain makes
a chemical and now you're feeling more
unlimited you're feeling more whole
you're teaching your body chemically to
understand what your mind intellectually
understood stood and now you are
literally literally starting to embody
that knowledge yes it's becoming
signaling new jesus it's new information
but but you can't do it one day and
expect your wealth to come you got to do
it over and over again yeah so the
repetition
of practicing over and over again
neurochemically conditions the mind and
body begin to work as one you've done it
so many times the body now knows how to
do it subconsciously
just like it just like i knew how to
subconsciously lean into trauma and
victim mode right decades now the body's
getting new information it's going to
adapt and and now
you're going to literally become
that knowledge you're going to become it
that's what you're going to become and
so now that's when you no longer have to
try it's who you are it's yes yeah
you've memorized an internal order
that's greater than anything in your
outer world that's going to tell you
something else that's key right there
and rule number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips is push
yourself i was looking uh closely and
there are people
that do
this work do do this transformation work
in the meditations that we teach and
they're so impatient and they're so
entitled
uh and they want an instantaneous change
from the lack
of feeling right
that they never overcome themselves in
their meditation they never overcome
themselves in the meditation and when
they finish their meditation they
believe in this work less
then there are people who say
i can tell you the moment i made up my
mind to change
because i had reached the end and i made
a decision
and that decision to change carried an
amplitude of energy that was greater
than the hardwired programs in my brain
and the emotional conditioning in my
body and my body literally responded to
my mind in that moment that the choice
that i made became a moment in time i
would never forget and they'll tell you
and that's the moment i remembered when
i was gonna change now
those people then when they sit down to
do the work
the chemotherapy hasn't worked
uh the injections didn't work uh the
radiation didn't work
uh the surgery didn't work the diet
didn't work the yoga didn't work this is
this is now their end they have nothing
else to believe in but themselves
and they go all in not 50 not 60
they're going all in they have nothing
else to believe in
now listen
when they go a little bit outside the
gnome they got they went a little
further than where they normally would
stop they pushed themselves to that next
limit
they started believing in themselves
that they could do it a little bit more
they
they finish the meditation and they get
up and believing it's it's it's working
more than working less they're they're
the person that's believing in
themselves that's why because it's not
the work it's your belief in yourself
right it's and then when you believe in
yourself you believe in possibilities
when you believe in possibilities you
got to believe in yourself
the concept the word meditation
literally means
to become familiar with if you look at
the symbolism of it and you look it up
as familiarization so
you sit down and you say okay i don't
want to be unhappy
i don't want to be angry i don't want to
talk trash about t people i don't want
to complain i want to blame i don't want
to make excuses i don't want to feel
lack i don't want to have an attitude
that's
telling me i can it's too hard that's
the old identity right
so the moment you start becoming
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts
the moment you become aware of your
automatic habits and behaviors the
moment you can notice that this is
actually guilt that you're feeling or
sadness or pain
the moment you can become conscious and
familiar
with those states of mind and body
if you keep becoming familiar with it if
you keep becoming conscious of it you
won't go unconscious so sitting in a
meditation to know thyself most people
all of a sudden here comes the barrage
of thoughts here comes the the
propensities and habits and here comes
the emotions the body's saying you
normally complain at this time what are
you doing sitting with your eyes closed
let's think of a reason why you can
complain and the body starts influencing
the mind so
you break it if you break it down if you
break it down to a for
for a person to understand how many
times
do we have to
forget
until we start remembering and keep
remembering and stop forgetting that's
the process of change
so then you to put a person in a
meditation and they hear that voice they
hear that chatter they they want to get
up and take
go to the bathroom they want to check
their cell phone they want to feel angry
and instead of getting up and saying i
can't meditate
see that's they're coming to the end of
the known so they want to go back to
what's known right
if you ask if you teach the person what
to do
and you show them that on the other side
of that is freedom on the other side of
that is joy it you got to become so
conscious and it takes a lot of
awareness it takes a lot of energy to
sit with yourself long enough to
disentangle from those programs now we
now know
that it's a formula that if you follow a
formula you will actually start pruning
circuitry you'll start the condition
stop the conditioning process and move
the body out of the past and it starts
liberating energy and that's that's
energy to heal with that's energy to
create a new life that's energy to
digest again that's the body's no longer
living in survival or living in
emergency and
the majority of people's emotions then
tend to be derived from the hormones of
stress and
and so so that we started realizing that
the arousal of the stress hormones
the the rush of the chemistry is
actually tapping the body's resources
and the stronger the emotions we feel
towards any problem or person in our
life the more we pay attention to them
and if where you place your attention is
where you place your energy
then you're giving your power away to
that person or problem and if a person
can learn to sit in the fire
and say it's not my boss
it's not my ex it's not my job it's not
the pandemic it's me that this emotion
isn't serving me because this emotion is
the exact emotion that's pushing the
genetic buttons that's creating disease
okay
if i can keep practicing lowering the
volume to that emotion
i'll keep taking my attention off that
person or problem and in a sense the
body starts moving back where into the
present moment it starts getting relaxed
in the in the unknown
so we started teaching people the
process and and by a person
overcoming their past not not
nothing not the trauma
just the emotion they just have to work
on
breaking that conditioning process
because if you keep doing it over and
over again a habit is when the body
becomes the mind now the servant now the
body's influencing the mind so
we teach a person then how to break that
conditioning process
the body starts moving into the present
moment it's no longer in the same
environmental condition and then all of
a sudden we start to see some pretty
dramatic changes in people's health you
think
sixty to seventy thousand thoughts
in one day
out of those sixty to seventy thousand
thoughts that you think in one day
ninety percent of those thoughts
are the same thoughts
as the day before
so if you believe that your thoughts
somehow are connected to your life
then the same thoughts always lead to
the same choices
the same choices always lead to the same
behaviors
the same behaviors create the same
experiences
and the same experiences produce the
same emotions
and those very same emotions drive the
very same thoughts
and your biology
your neural circuitry
your neurochemistry your neural hormones
and even your genetic expression
is equal to how you think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think
how you act and how you feel is called
your personality
and your personality creates your
personal reality
that's it
so then if you wanted to create a new
personal reality
a new life
then you would have to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
and change it
you would have to become aware of your
unconscious thoughts
and observe them
you would have to pay attention to your
automatic habits and behaviors and
modify them
and you would have to look at the
emotions you live by every single day
that are connected to your past
and decide if those emotions belong in
your future
you see most people try to create a new
personal reality
as the same personality and it doesn't
work
you literally have to become someone
else i believe in free will i would
never tell anybody what to believe like
politically or
socially or whatever
i want to provide them the tools and
give them the free will to create life
however they want and believe whatever
they want that's totally cool with me
so those people then
that
want to be healed
and they live in fear
that fear has to be addressed i mean and
it's not easy
because it's
hardwired deep in the limbic brain it's
just a safety net it's a mechanism so
then imagine being in the unknown
that the instinct and the unknown is
it's a scary place
wow imagine not having a body and we
practice lingering without a body in in
in an infinite space and without a name
without a face without a culture without
a job without a social security number
without a disease without a diet just as
an awareness you you practice that
you're going to be comfortable in the
unknown you're going to relax more into
it that's going against
thousands of years
of programming and the people who
actually overcome their fear
and they trade it for gratitude their
immune system gets stronger their genes
up regulated i mean there's just a host
of
everything their brain changes their
heart rate variability
they feel differently and it's it's
being measured and and some of these
people
we're measuring this now in our in our
events with with reputable scientists
and in universities they're they're
shocked
at what they're witnessing on a cellular
level on a brain level on a heart level
they cannot
believe the capacity of the body i i
just
was i just got an email today of a site
one of our scientists said i ran this
three times
the virus
that we exposed the cell to in advanced
meditators does not enter the cell it's
outside the cell it will a virus in
novice meditators some of it's in the
cell some of it's outside controls all
the viruses in the cell there's an
immunity so when the person's less
reactionary to their environment
there's less of response that weakens
them they're less of a victim to their
environment then they're less of a
victim to their environment
large scale small scale the body has a
greater immunity to whatever it is bond
university
a university in australia on the gold
coast
senior researcher took the large
majority of my brain scans
and they hadn't she had them analyzed by
her graduate students and they
statistically looked at everything
one of the most startling things for the
research team
was our community's ability
to go to
to get to that point where they're
nobody no one no thing nowhere in no
time i'm talking four seconds i'm
talking five seconds i'm talking nine
seconds just like just give me a second
i know how to do this they they've
practiced it enough times that the
creative moment is when you get beyond
yourself when you dissociate from
everything known in your material world
turns out when you do that and you start
changing your brain waves
your brain waves slow down into alpha
and theta
you're suppressing the memory bank of
the known self that keeps you plugged
into three-dimensional reality when you
quiet down this mechanism
now
all of a sudden you start connecting to
that field and when you can stay
conscious in those subconscious realms
when you can literally regulate and
change brain waves now you're in the
operating system where you can make
those significant changes here's the
deal with trauma and it's kind of an
interesting thing because when you're
traumatized
some threat or some danger or some
condition in your outer world
through your senses is changing how you
feel in your inner world
and the quotient of change between the
way you normally feel
in some alarm state when you change your
internal state and move into that
emergency mode you narrow your focus
on the cause and the brain
freezes an image and takes a snapshot
and that's called the long-term memory
and now that image is branded
holographically into the brain
so then
they remember experience remember
experience is better because we can
remember how they feel and and that
memory then changes the person's biology
so they think neurologically within the
circuits of that experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and how we think and feel
becomes our state of being
so now the person
biologically has changed and many times
it's the strong emotion that begins to
select and instruct the gene that
creates disease why
because if the environment signals the
gene and that's the truth that's
epigenetics and the end product of an
experience in the environment is an
emotion
the emotion that you feel from that
event is literally selecting the gene
are you to begin to change and genes
make proteins and so the the person if
it's if it's strong enough begins to
wear their trauma not just in their
brain
now it's in their body because every
time they think about that trauma every
time they review it every time they keep
creating the imagery they keep firing
and wiring the circuits in their brain
and they keep feeling the feeling
emotionally in their body and their body
is so objective
that it's believing it's living in the
same past experience 50 to 100 times a
day and all you need is a stimulus and
response an image and an emotion a
thought and a feeling and you're
conditioning the body into the past well
you're conditioning the brain body into
the past why is our memory
for
pain stronger than our memory of a
success or a joy i really think that
when the survival gene is activated
preservation is the key so we can have
10 things
that happen really great in our lives
you have a family member or somebody you
know that does this they have ten really
great things happen in their one thing
bed and they focus on that bad thing why
because the survival genes activated
they want to make sure it doesn't happen
again so so you put your attention on it
because you don't want it to happen
again so what people do when they're
aroused is there to start thinking it's
going to happen so they actually select
the worst
case scenario in their mind
and then emotionally embrace that future
before it happens
and they're conditioning their body to
become the mind of anxiety and fear so
in preservation and in survival if you
prepare for the worst
anything less that happens you have a
better chance of surviving so that's the
mechanism that takes place so
survival means you better take care of
your body yeah you better be aware of
your environment and make sure there's
no threats and so you got to keep your
eye out there
and you better be thinking about the
future based on what you learned in the
past now there's nothing wrong with that
when the analytical facilities are in
balance but when there's an arousal
arousal there's three things that create
arousal fear
hostility and anger or aggression and
pain
and that arousal drives the brain
into these high states of what we call
high beta
and most people need something or
someone or some circumstance or some
drug or some pill or some computer game
to change that internal state and the
moment they notice a change in their
internal state then they pay attention
to what's causing it they start
developing a dependency on it right
so
it turns out that when we teach people
how to self-regulate and change their
brain waves we could actually see then
that the incoherence the disorderliness
that's taking place in the brain you
know when you're over aroused you're
overly analytical and you're shifting
your attention from one problem to one
person to one thing to one place to
another problem to another circumstance
to your phone to your car and each one
of those elements has a neurological
network in the brain so the arousal
causes these different circuits to fire
out of order and the brain is incoherent
so take two waves that are out of phase
and mix them when they interfere they
flatten out there's no energy so energy
leaves the brain right
so then
when you're in arousal you narrow your
focus on the cause if there's something
rattling in the bushes and it's dark you
freeze and you narrow your focus on it
and there's a rush of adrenaline and
your pupils dilate and your heart starts
to race and you're ready to run fight or
hide i mean that's a survival moment but
what if it's your co-worker
sitting right next to you or six feet
away and and you're judging them you're
the same arousal's taking place and
what's once very adaptive becomes very
maladaptive now this is where it gets
challenging so when we teach people how
to open their focus we've done
thousands and thousands of brain scans
and they get beyond their analytical
processes and they open their awareness
and go from a conversion focus to a
divergent focus and they learn how to
relax and regulate their brain waves
start to slow down into alpha and then
if they do it properly and they're
connecting
those different compartments of the
brain that were once firing out of order
start to unify different communities
form bigger communities the brain starts
to synchronize and then all of a sudden
you start seeing different compartments
of the brain all in resonance so now
when they're all in resonance and they
start interfering when those waves come
together there's more energy in the
brain
so when a person dials down the
mechanism this neocortex that plugs us
into three-dimensional reality that
keeps us aware of our body that's the
autobiographical self where everything's
stitched in memory in there when we
start deactivating the mechanism here
and we get beyond the memory bank of the
known self and brainwaves move into
theta we
we've studied this so much
when a person can let their body
be in a light state of sleep and feel so
safe
that you can finally let go and
surrender the body is
sleeping but the mind is awake and now
the door between the conscious mind and
the subconscious mind is wide open
if they can regulate and stay there
something amazing happens
there is a release of energy
from the body and their brain goes into
a very very super coherent state of
gamma and gamma is super consciousness
now i'm not talking about
a little gamma i'm not talking about a
lot of gamma i'm not talking about a
really loud gamma i'm talking about a
supernatural amount of gamma
there's so much order
and so much energy in the brain like if
we were in an audience and we were all
clapping like this
that could be alpha right theta would
be and if everybody could do this the
slower we could do it the more we can
get our timing down the more we can get
coherent but if we were doing
this it would be really hard for all of
us to do that at the same time it takes
a lot of order a lot of awareness a lot
of energy to be able to create that kind
of
order so
that's how fast the brain is and that
arousal
that's taking place is ecstasy
that arousal is bliss it is the most
familiar
unfamiliar feeling that people ever have
and
that memory then
that the person has that is so
profoundly different
than the feeling of success
the feeling of wealth the feeling of
orgasm or love or whatever this is a new
one and it's a thrill
and the person notices a dramatic change
in their inner state
and with that experience comes a very
lucid picture
a very profound insight a download of
information
that's the moment then
the body many times rewrites the
biological program energy
is in forming matter and the autonomic
nervous system is regulating it's in
high order and remember disease is
autonomic dysregulation
now it's getting into a very very high
frequency of order and it's sending very
coherent information
to the cells and tissues sending energy
to the cells and tissues and cells begin
to emit more coherent light and
information and then there's the disease
and there it's not the recognition that
when you're assimilating a negative
thought or a negative judgment
or a negative emotion envy
greed whatever it may be
that's actually lowering your energy
yeah and when you get to that place
where you're experiencing that
incredible bliss right here you can you
can't yeah and even if you have the
thought and the thought will still come
because we still have those stories but
the thought
will be an understanding of human nature
because you're no longer
at that vibrational level anymore you're
rising above it you know and and i think
more and more people are starting to
figure that out and and and the people
in their lives are like no my husband
my husband is a changed person no he's
not the same guy i know him i know he's
completely different and the guy is just
like yeah i feel amazing i feel great
and all it was was sitting in the fire
yes for a little bit of time until the
body finally moved out of the past into
the present moment and so
the causes of this like i always say you
never know
what you're doing today and how you're
doing it who you're going to affect
tomorrow when you do this work and
that's what we're seeing and people are
they're they're they're getting
promotions
uh they're getting all these wonderful
things not because
of anything that they're doing
they're just different yeah and people
notice that and they want those people
in the position to make better decisions
for the whole and i think that's uh
that's how we change the world in our
community at least people who have
relationships that are built
from our community
tend to be more long-lasting because
they're more self-aware and so there's
no blame there's no excuses there's no
make wrong there's no competition
there's none of that there's just this
is who i am you know and i think that
the ultimate goal is
when you reach the point in your life
when how you appear to the world
is who you really are that level of
transparency is it takes no effort right
you can be yourself and and
and you know people say to me wow you're
pretty approachable and i say
well god i work so hard every day on
overcoming myself in the morning
overcoming my ego why would i want to
build it up the next day because i got
to face that guy again tomorrow morning
so why not just keep you know you know
taking those edges and smoothing them
down so that so that
you're you're less
unconscious to all of those programs
that are built in relationships and you
asked if is it possible then can that
people can heal that quickly in one week
yeah because what if they create an
inner event
that carries an amplitude of gratitude
or joy or freedom breakthrough from the
chains of the past when the body is
liberated and you feel that elevated
emotion
the stronger the emotion you feel from
that breakthrough the more you're going
to pay attention to the image in your
mind and now you're now beginning to
brand new circuitry in the brain and
your body's being conditioned into a new
future and the stronger the emotion you
feel and the more you pay attention to
the picture the more you're conditioning
the body over time to the future instead
of the past so now
you keep knocking on that genetic door
emotionally
then that emotion ultimately signals a
new gene that
up regulates that gene to produce better
proteins and the person then all of a
sudden
starts healing and we have research to
show
that people can do that in four days
signal genes to reduce cancer cells and
wow just to signal stem cells to to
suppress um
uh to go to active tissues and repair
them and regenerate them and suppress
inflammation you know you come with a
lot of genes and they're just a library
of potentials they're just a storehouse
of information of possibilities so then
you got to get the right signal the
right lock into the key that begins to
select and instruct genes that cause
genes to make different proteins and you
can regulate so many different genes the
same genes you can regulate them
differently so when they up regulate
they start producing really healthy and
robust proteins and that's that's
enzymes that's tissue that structure
that's function that's hormones
it's immune immunoglobulins when they
down regulate because of some alarm when
there's not a lot of energy
for long-term building projects well
then you keep doing that then the body
starts producing cheaper proteins it's a
different signal it's not a time for
growth when you hit pay dirt like that
when you connect when you connect to the
field when you connect the divine
whatever you want to call it when your
consciousness merges with a greater
consciousness and that arousal creates
ecstasy bliss oneness whatever you want
to call that
you realize that it never came from
anything out there it didn't come from
the wardrobe or the facelift the sports
car or whatever
it came from within you and so you stop
looking out there for it and now the
love affair begins and you never want to
miss a date because it's just too good
so that memory then
that is what i'm after
because when you have those
transcendental moments and you
understand this yeah
the experience of that transcendental
moment lays down new circuitry in the
brain that's what experience does
and the experience produces a feeling
but it's not chemical it's electric and
it's orderly and every cell of your body
is
jiggling in an order and there and
you're aroused and you're awakened right
you have to admit when that occurs
your spectrum of reality is going to
broaden some conditioning
some illusion something is removed and
you start seeing reality as it is and
all of a sudden you start seeing the
part that we edit out for survival
now you start seeing patterns and lights
and information
that are transcendent of
three-dimensional reality and your
spectrum why because your brain had the
experience and the circuitry's there and
now your your experience of the world
changes you get an upgrade to the to the
vr set the virtual reality said oh you
got the upgrade you got 2.0 and now it
looks different everything looks
different everybody looks different the
world look you're seeing beauty more
well and there's more holism and more
connection and sounds and words and
music and sense and sight and light is
all working together i mean that's the
blessing of an awakening right that's
where that's where we're going what do
you think the world humanities challenge
will be over the next decade as we enter
2020
um back to the principle lewis of just
different paradigms beginning
to collapse
you know economically politically
socially environmentally religiously
education journalism the you know
medicine
they they have to
uh move into chaos
and chaos is just unpredictable
yeah exactly but now here's the
challenge for humanity
you have one of two ways to embrace the
breakdown of those those those paradigms
you can face them with anger and
hostility and fear and you are only
contributing to more of it
uh we have to see that those breakdowns
are essential for something greater to
happen
now
we can't wait
for governments to take care of us
that's we can't wait for
uh medicine to to give us a drug that's
going to heal us from a condition the
truth is with a greater level of
consciousness
the change in awareness because of
information
the greatest challenge we have as those
as those paradigms break down is to no
longer emotionally react in the same way
and be victims you can't say this
president this person this this whatever
is actually making me feel this way and
think this way basically you're in the
program that you're something outside of
you is controlling you
how you feel and how you think
so then to self-regulate then is to say
how i think and feel was going to change
my outer environment so then
we're all faced with great opportunities
brilliantly disguised as impossible
situations and we are at that point at
that nexus point in our evolution as a
species so then you don't try to fix
that that's never going to work what you
do is you create something better
and then everybody just naturally just
leaves that
and goes here now it used to be some
people would just come here and the
majority would stay here because they're
clinging to
what they've been programmed or
believing but now
because of information everybody's like
that's not going to work i already know
it's not going to work and i don't care
what anybody says this is working for me
so
people are moving to new to new um
to new applications to new paradigms
because it's working for them so as long
as we don't emotionally react to the
breakdown that's happening
currently in the world and chaos is just
unpredictable order you know as as as
things move towards disorder the novelty
that's being created is literally chaos
because
the known
and everything staying the same
is order
but as you step out into that unknown
it's then you're having the chaos is
unpredictable order being expressed
through novelty and we have to be able
to learn how to take that
disorder and with the application of
brain and heart coherence create more
order so you can't just say hey i'm
standing up for peace and you know and
being being
miserable with your coworker you you
don't get to talk about peace
until there's you you're the you're the
living prayer of peace not just we know
we know crime rates go down and
violence goes down when there's peace
projects in communities where there's
meditation on peace but when
those peace gathering projects end you
know you see that crime and violence and
everything returns back to the same
level so it's not enough to just think
it
we got to demonstrate it so if i'm
demonstrating peace and you're
demonstrating peace somebody else
because of mere neurons is going to go
wow that person is unpredictable wow
they're different it's given me
permission to do the same
so i think that
ultimately moving into that state of
being you know as human beings and and
and creating unity
that you know you keep watching so many
programs on television that talk you
into prejudice that talk you into
separation that talk you into fear that
talk you into violence that talk you
into war deceit
negativity
you're you're not going to trust anybody
in fact you're going to see difference
between you and me or anybody because
that's what separation does but
when you're heart centered and you feel
connected you don't see the person any
longer right you see something
transcendent you see in essence right
and i think
if you do that really well
that kind of emergence of a of a new
consciousness
but that's less dependent
on on all of those outer things is
really difficult to control and you want
to control a community control their
emotions
and control them in survival when you
overcome your emotions
you can see the hidden meaning behind
all things and when everybody's looking
this way you may be looking that way
because you understand look you've just
overcome your fear you've just overcome
your hostility and anger you've overcome
the program of whatever it is
i swear to you you are going to be able
to connect people and that that then
is the hope of the future
if something outside of you is
controlling your feelings and thoughts
then it makes you a victim to your
environment so then yes so you will be
more victimized or more you could be
more of a victim to other things in your
environment people don't understand this
consciously because it's a program
subconsciously
so
so now
if you begin to strengthen your inner
environment now this is where our work
comes in because we have research to
show
that when you place your attention right
here in your heart this
center right here this is this is the
beginning of our divinity this is our
center of oneness our wholeness this is
where we begin to feel love gratitude
compassion kindness care freedom joy
it's all these elevated emotions that
are heartfelt emotions that our research
shows
that when you begin to teach people how
to open this center
and you teach them a formula on how to
practice it
that if they did that for
four days
that
they would begin to strengthen their
immune system by 50 percent now let me
tell you why because in the center
is your heart but what most people don't
know there's another gland in there
called the thymus gland
fine leaf it's named after the the the
time leaf and the thymus gland has two
functions it has an endocrinological
function it makes growth hormone that's
our youth center
and it makes
uh strong immune chemicals and it has an
immunological function
so when you're living by stress and your
heart is racing and you're stepping on
the gas and the brake at the same time
because you can't run you can't fight
you can't hide
and you got the gas in the clutch cone
energy is going to leave the harness
going to the adrenal center and you're
going to cause contraction in the
arteries in your heart and this center
will shut down from blood flow and so
there's no energy in the heart so you
teach a person then how to begin to open
the center and to start feeling elevated
emotions through their heart and you
teach them how to switch or convert from
the sympathetic nervous system to the
parasympathetic nervous system
well all of a sudden now this thymus
gland which normally shrinks
with age starting at puberty
the fountain of youth now
all of a sudden begins to get new blood
flow
and there's new hormones that are
signaled like oxytocin
and vasopressin
and all these different chemicals called
nitric oxide an endothelial derived
relaxing factor and the arteries in the
heart begin to swell with energy and
blood flow and this center switches on
and now it says man this feels good
and this is a time for us to really get
back into balance
and really let's strengthen our inner
world
and now all of a sudden
this thymus gland begins to make
thymusin which is an important agent
that begins to make t cells and t cells
have little receptors on them called t
cell receptors
and when those t cell receptors are
robust and strong
those cells
make proteins and they make what's
called antibodies or immune
immunoglobulins
and these little y-shaped proteins block
the receptors coming from the virus that
are trying to attack the white blood
cells they have a shield and now
they're they're immune
to the to the virus
and its attack with its receptor
and it can literally begin to inject it
with these immunoglobulins primary
immunoglobulin a
and that begins to cause the virus to
not survive wow then that white blood
cell will cut
past another white blood cell and pass
on the memory to it so it already knows
what's coming so now
all of a sudden you're making these
immunoglobulins and now your inner world
now can combat anything that's that's a
foreign agent and even cancer cells if
you're alive in this world and you
haven't been experiencing the quickening
i mean i mean
you know i said to uh
someone the other day
the day where you end your day and feel
complete because you finished all your
work you'll never have that you know
there's always more emails and more
things to check right so the demand has
has has pressed us into this crazy realm
of
of uh of of um multitasking
and i think that
you start shifting where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
so if you're shifting your attention all
over the board your energy is scattered
yeah so then when you start
disconnecting from everybody your boss
your co-worker you know the news uh your
cell phone your computer and you start
going this way
i think it's uh into the present moment
then of where you place your attention
is where you place your energy and
you're truly in the present moment
you've got a lot of energy to execute
you've got to lend an energy to use and
you want to be able to do that eyes open
the more scattered your energy the less
you have to focus on pushing one thing
forward that's why people's dreams don't
happen because they're scattered
there's no look look if you keep putting
your attention on some future experience
that you are imagining with your mind
your body is going to follow your mind
right there because that's where your
energy is but if you're putting your
attention on everything known in your
life the shower the coffee maker you
know
the toilet and your body's following
your mind every day to the known but we
want your body to follow your mind to
the unknown right enough people get to
doing that
and you could do better in creating
things in your life that we see this
wealthy people in our work that have
focused on wealth some of them living in
the back seat of their car some of them
bankrupt that now have multi-million
dollar companies what do you think they
want to do with that money
they want to give it away yeah give it
back let me tell you why not because of
any other reason is that they now know
that they create more right well why why
if you're abundant why
abundance to me has changed abundance
means i have more than i need like way
more than i need so if i have way more
than i need and i know how to create it
then take it i'll create more of it so
now you're no longer holding on in
scarcity
you're making a difference so wealthy
people that have created a lot of wealth
in this work they want to give back they
want to make a difference and i think
that that's how we're innately wired i
think we're all innately wired to care
for one another to make a difference in
the living organism our living organism
our community we heal one another that's
what we do right we inform one another
we encourage one another we support one
another
we shine for one another not to outshine
another person to shine to show them
they can shine and that's that to me is
super healthy so then i'm i'm applauding
your success because i want you to
succeed because you're telling me that
if you can do it i can do it so so
there's no longer any separation i think
that's hopeful for the world then you
start celebrating diversity then you're
like wow you're way different than me i
want to i want to study you because i
want to bring that into who i'm becoming
what are the things that
disturb or
disconnect our awakening and connection
to the divine a lot of times when people
they hit that point they try to
reproduce it the same way as we talked
about and you can't yeah you can't do it
the same way because that's redundancy
but also many times
we have the experience and we start to
try
and because trying is matter trying to
change matter and and so we're forcing
we're controlling we're predicting and
and then the uh and when we do that then
of course we're in separation and we're
waiting for the event to happen to feel
the emotion right and
i've done that
long enough and it's actually we have to
lay down
the very thing we used our whole life to
get what we want for something greater
to occur and it takes practice of
surrender right
so
that's one element i also think that our
responses emotionally
like
let's just say that a person gets
connected to the future they get
connected to the energy of their future
they feel it it's really great and then
they start their day and then two hours
later they're they're feeling something
else because some person or some
circumstance altered their state well
they just disconnected from the energy
of the future and now they're back to
the energy of the past don't expect
anything to change in your life because
then work that way so then
then when they get back to that old self
again then they say what's wrong with me
i failed they didn't do it right no
that's all the program you show up again
and you go after it again
uh so familiar feelings uh cause us
to no longer see through the lens of the
future we're seeing through the lens of
the past
and and we color reality that way so
um
i think i think familiar emotions uh get
in the way as well and then of course
there's always belief
and a belief is just a thought you keep
thinking over and over again until you
hardwire it in your brain and all
beliefs are based on past experience a
person has an experience the stronger
the emotion they have from that
circumstance the more they pay attention
to the cause and the brain freezes a
frame takes a snapshot and that's called
the memory
the moment they draw a conclusion about
that experience they'll think
neurologically within those circuits and
they'll feel chemically within the
boundaries of emotion thinking and
feeling thinking and feeling
belief becomes an unconscious or
subconscious state of being they don't
most people don't even know they have
beliefs about things about god about
relationships about money because it's
it's not a conscious thing it's a
subconscious thing yeah so in order to
change a belief or a perception
about yourself and your life
you got to go all in
it's not like you go 50 in you got to go
all in you got to make a decision
with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that causes the body to respond to the
mind that the choice that you make
becomes a moment in time you'll never
forget and you would say i remember the
moment
i made up my mind to change and the
stronger the emotion you feel the more
you'll pay attention to the decision and
that's a huge stone you drop in the
quantum field big splash big waves your
brain is organized to reflect everything
you know in your life
your brain
is a record of the past
it's an artifact
of all the things you've learned and
experienced to this moment
so if you wake up every morning
and get out of bed on the same side
shut the alarm clock off with the same
finger
shuffle into the bathroom and use the
toilet like you always do
go and get a cup of coffee and drink
coffee out of your favorite mug
then get in the shower and wash yourself
off in the same routine way
drive to work
get to work see the same people
that push the same emotional buttons do
the same things that you've memorized
and do so well
then hurry up and go home
and hurry up and check your emails
and hurry up and check your facebook and
then watch your favorite television show
then hurry up and go to bed
here's my question
did your brain change at all that day
we could say that you were thinking the
same thoughts performing the same
unconscious actions
living by the same emotions but secretly
expecting your life to change
so there's a principle in neuroscience
and the principle says
nerve cells that fire together
wire together
so if you're thinking the same thoughts
making the same choices
demonstrating the same behaviors
reproducing the same experiences that
stamp the same networks of neurons into
the same patterns
and then produce the same emotions
you're going to hardwire your brain
into a very finite signature
because as you fire and wire the same
circuits in the same way
those circuits begin to become more
connected
and by the time you're 35 years old this
is science now
we become a set of memorized behaviors
unconscious habits
automatic emotional reactions beliefs
and perceptions and even attitudes that
function
just like a computer program
and if you do something over and over
and over again
the repetition of those actions over
time conditions your body to know how to
do it well better than your mind
and a habit is when your body knows
better than your mind
where you've done something so many
times that the body now knows how to do
it better than the brain
and so 95 percent of most people's
behaviors
attitudes thoughts beliefs
emotional reactions are subconscious
programs
so why is that important
because you're here this week
to learn new information
and every time you learn something new
you make new connections in your brain
that's what learning is
learning is forging new synaptic
connections
physical evidence
as a result of your interaction in the
environment
and the footprints of consciousness is
called learning making new connections
and the nobel prize laureate kandel in
the year 2000
found that when people learned one bit
of information
they doubled the number of connections
in their brain
from 1300 connections to 2600
connections
but if they didn't review that
information
if they couldn't repeat it
if they couldn't remember it those
circuits pruned apart in hours or days
so if learning is making new synaptic
connections
then remembering is maintaining and
sustaining those connections your body
rejects viruses all the time of course
it has memorized certain viruses that
you've been exposed to it's memorized
certain bacteria that you've been
exposed to and it's beaten those viruses
not every virus wins in the body the
body has an intelligence and it's and it
has
quite a library of memories in the in
the in the white blood cells so your
body is fighting viruses and bacteria
all the time there's a constant
competition going on really so our
research shows that four days
of opening your heart releases
immunoglobulin a your body's primary
defense against bacteria and viruses
it's better than the flu shot it's the
body's natural flu shot and that's the
innate intelligence of the body saying i
got this i got a lot of energy in fact i
got a surplus of energy in fact i'm
radiating energy and now too much around
the world well now my outer world is not
controlling my inner world my inner
world now is functioning independent of
what's going on in my outer world and
now you're manifesting your manifesto ah
now you got it now you're in a creative
state because people are coming to you
yes right exactly now you're a magnet
now you have a field right and you have
energy
to heal and our research shows that that
field around your body will actually
expand you you radiate more light and
information cells
are getting new information that that
are causing
light to be exchanged between cells and
information now the body's getting an
upgrade so
so that immunoglobulin a in four days
went up fifty percent
so now we now know that if it's going up
fifty percent that then the immune
system was getting a new signal
and nitric oxide then
causes another chemical to activate the
arteries in your heart to swell and now
just like when energy moves into your
sexual organs and it swells with blood
and you have energy there the same
intensity it moves into your heart
and now
now the heart is activated and what do
you feel
you feel an incredible amount of love
yeah
you feel you feel whole and now the more
whole you feel our research shows
then the less separate you feel from the
things you want in your life because
you feel like you already have them you
only want things when you're in lack but
when you feel whole then it feels like
it's already happened and that tends to
be the exact emotion
that causes those synchronicities and
serendipities and coincidences to happen
in our life and you say to a person what
are you doing and they're saying i'm not
doing anything
i'm just i'm loving life i'm being
myself i'm yeah right i'm free i'm free
from the past i'm free from my story of
the past in fact i'm more connected to
the energy of my future than i am to the
energy of my past i think that if we
share
the same experiences because we like the
same things
we share the same emotions
and if we share the same experiences we
share the same emotions i can relate to
you so we can exchange ideas and
information yeah and if we share the
same energy energy is information so
many people as an example
they use each other to reaffirm their
their dependency on suffering so i
suffer more than you then you say i you
i suffer you suffer more than me we have
this thing we just complain with each
other well that's the same resonance the
same frequency and there's a match right
but goes to the same means if you if
you're if you're someone who's has a uh
accountability partner that that you
exchange ideas like this with and it's a
different frequency and different energy
so
when energy comes together and it's
constructive something comes out of it
yeah you feel it right it's and you feel
an elevation if there's dissonance then
your your sensing meter is how you feel
about that person many times in your gut
or in your heart or wherever and there's
deconstruct there's a destructive
interference and there's no energy
involved so
i think that's just a practice but
really
the ultimate mastery
is to be able to be in such residence
such coherence
that when you walk in the room that you
raise
everybody's energy and you don't let
your energy drop because of any
circumstance or any condition then that
would be greater than your environment
right and that's that's the model
that we use so imagine 1 500 people
in an event
where everybody's getting super coherent
and the interference that's going on in
the room is creating these high
amplitudes and we've measured that in
the room and the energy in the room is
off the chart many times there's i mean
there's energy for healing in there
there's energy for all kinds of things
that can happen so we brought it to life
with our awareness and so
the more elevated the emotion love
gratitude freedom bliss ecstasy the
higher the frequency
so but it turns out you can have a
collective group of people with a lot of
energy and be incoherent and it creates
entropy yeah you could have a smaller
group of people that are highly coherent
and put out a very big signal
so when we see a collective really get
coherent
wow the energy in the room opens up
doors
of possibilities that i would i would
never expect i mean i i don't i don't
know how to explain some of the
phenomenological things that happen
but that's that's everybody's divine
like everybody's everybody's in that
state they're they're in that elevated
state so
i think our i think our truth meter
is really whether we feel it lifted
uh or we feel like we've been robbed if
you are not
defined by some vision
that is bigger than you
and you are not passionate about that
vision then you're left with the old
hardware of the past in your brain and
you will be predictable in your life
so would you agree then
new thoughts
new information should lead to new
choices
new choices should lead to new behaviors
and new behaviors should create new
experiences
and new experiences should produce new
emotions
and those new emotions should drive new
thoughts and that's called evolution
so if your brain is a record of the past
and you don't have a vision of the
future
then you are living in the past
and you will never arrive at that new
future if you have been an experienced
uh if you had experience of trauma say
for example and it's created the feeling
of fear and your fear is that it could
happen again
and you're you don't know this but every
time you think about that future that
possible worst case scenario scenario
and you feel the emotion you're
conditioning your body to become the
mind subconsciously of anxiety
so now
all you need now is some cue in your
outer environment that says it's unsafe
that if there's damage there that you're
you're a victim something's bigger than
you that could have an effect on you
well now
that feeling of fear
is going to cause you to think thoughts
equal to it
so the person then
no longer needs the environment to feel
that fear they just to have to have the
thought about
that condition now and now
they're literally knocking their brain
and body out of balance by thought alone
and the body's constantly living in
emergency mode and it takes a lot of
energy
a lot of resources to live in emergency
mode all the time
guess what system becomes compromised by
the immune system your immune system why
because you have two protection systems
you gotta get a system that protects you
from dangers in your outer world that's
that's the gas pedal that's the
sympathetic nervous system that's a
fight-or-flight nervous system danger
threat out there use all the energy
because you gotta you gotta survive and
when you survive you got to take care of
your body so right so so now
that system can work really well short
term
it doesn't work really well if you keep
it on all the time because if you're
mobilizing all that energy for some
threat in your outer world there's no
energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building projects and energy
leaves the brain and it leaves the heart
and it moves into these lower centers
because now you're tapping the body's
resources because there is an emergency
but whether the emergency is real or
imagined
whether your anger is valid or justified
or not
that the you're tapping the body's very
energy to heal by doing this and the
immune system says
well we're part of really the other
nervous system we're the break we're the
clutch we need the we need to get into
relaxation we need to get back into
balance again and and when we do then
we'll metabolize then we'll we'll
assimilate we'll reproduce we'll
excrete properly
so
so now you got a this kind of battle
between the gas pedal and the brake and
the immune system says hey listen if
there's foreign agents if there's
viruses bacteria molds funguses listen
we don't have a whole lot of energy here
to deal with them because we're fighting
this war out there there's no homeland
security so they shut down
certain receptors in the immune system
they shut down function
of those lymphocytes those white blood
cells that are your inner army of
protection
and it takes a lot of energy to fight a
virus in a bacteria but if there's no
energy hey listen it takes energy to
raise the body's temperature where do
you think that comes from that's part of
that branch called the autonomic nervous
system and the sympathetic the gas pedal
is part of it and the parasympathetic is
the clutch is part of that autonomic
nervous system and it's a check and
balance but so you stay in emergency for
an extended period of time
and now you're exposed to some
antigen or some
external substance some foreign agent
when we become the living example of
truth when we actually embody this
that
there are no limits to what we can do
and i'm hopeful with human beings that
um
that we have this capacity
and uh and of course when we believe in
ourselves uh we believe in possibility
and when we believe in possibilities we
believe in ourselves and i think that is
the ultimate belief
feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you can remember experiences better
because you can remember how they feel
and when you're in the midst of an
experience
all of your senses plug you into the
environment
and as you're gathering all of this
vital data from your external world
all that information rushes back to your
brain
and it causes jungles of neurons to
organize themselves into networks
the moment those neurons string into
place the brain makes a chemical and
that chemical is called a feeling or an
emotion
and once you feel that emotion you
create a long-term memory
now reason this with me
if feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you are feeling the same way
every single day
doesn't that mean nothing new is
happening in your life
and if those feelings and emotions drive
certain thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel
because you had events in your life that
have branded you emotionally
and you feel sadness or guilt or shame
or unworthiness or insecurity
all of those emotions are created from
past experiences
and when you feel those emotions
and those emotions drive certain
thoughts
and then those thoughts make certain
chemicals for you to feel the same
emotion
and then those emotions drive certain
thoughts
the repetition of that cycle then
conditions the body
to memorize that emotional state better
than the mind
and now your body literally is in the
past
because if you can't think greater than
how you feel then you are thinking in
the past
and so most people then
spend the majority of their life
talking about
why they never arrive at their vision of
the future
because of some past experience
so if feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences you remember
your first kiss
you remember your wedding you remember
the birth of your children you remember
catching a fish off the coast of
manzanillo with your three best friends
because you caught the fish and it was a
new experience and you felt great
and then you went
to the casita and you cooked the
mahi-mahi and you drank sauvignon blanc
and the wind was blowing off the sea and
the sun was setting
and you made a long-term memory
but you also have memories that are
connected to trauma and crisis
to disappointments
and those are the memories that people
remember more than anything else
and so if you haven't overcome some
emotion
that keeps you anchored to the past
then you tell a story about the past
and people say
i am this way because of this experience
that happened to me
15 years ago
i am this way because of some event that
happened 30 years ago
and from a biological perspective
it means i haven't been able to change
in the last fifteen or thirty years
and scientific american
a prestigious magazine
says that fifty percent
of what you talk about in your past
isn't even the truth
you make it up
because you don't have the same brain
that you did 15 years ago or 30 years
ago
so then your brain and body are
typically in the past
because thoughts
are the language of the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body
and how you think and how you feel
creates your state of being
so if you think insecure thoughts
in a matter of seconds you are going to
feel insecure
the moment you feel insecure
your brain is monitoring how you're
feeling and you think more insecure
thoughts
which then makes you feel more insecure
and the repetition of that cycle
conditions the body to become the mind
of insecurity
and then the person says
i
am insecure
and whenever you say i am anything you
are commanding your mind and body into a
destiny
so then how do people change
they wait for crisis
trauma
disease
diagnosis loss
something has to go wrong in their life
where they feel so uncomfortable that
they finally make up their mind to
change
and why is that
because after the trauma or the crisis
they don't feel like of themselves
and the moment they don't feel like
themselves they could actually observe
themselves
because they are looking at themselves
through the eyes of someone else
but my message is why wait
you can learn and change in a state of
pain and suffering
or you can learn and change in a state
of joy and inspiration memory is
creative that in fact fifty percent of
that story you embellish
people make up that story let me tell
you why they make up that story
because they excuse themselves for the
fact that they haven't been able to
change
since that event they'll have to make it
sound worse than it really was to make
it harder to grow and change
so that they can reaffirm their limited
sense of their inability to change
so then that story becomes more and more
of a story it's less of the truth
because you got to work yourself up into
a state there were lions and tigers and
there were right you know there were
helicopters snowstorms yeah everybody
was firing bullets
worse than you could possibly imagine
and then you've got to feel that emotion
right and then you look at this oh yeah
it must have been really bad now that's
that's your identity now that's your
identity when things are bad you feel
bad so there's dramatic contrast and
polarity and this is the realm of
polarity right so how do you find the
middle path well the heart is the middle
path it's the union of polarity it's the
union of opposites it's it's oneness
it's wholeness and this is where we have
to begin to create from all of this down
here is all humanity this is all our
animal nature we get up in here things
change right
you go from selfish to selfless and
something else happens so
it's really funny too because when
a lot of people come they say i i don't
know i'm having difficulty opening my
heart
i'm you know i'm practicing but i'm not
feeling anything yet and then it comes
time to do our healings on other people
and
the moment you it was no longer about
you all of a sudden something happened
well of course that's what the heart is
about right so
so it comes in ways that we least expect
at times we have a huge frontal lobe and
it's 40 of our entire brain
and most people
uh when they have a thought they just
think that that's the truth and i think
one of my greatest
realizations in my own journey was
just because you have a thought doesn't
necessarily mean it's true
so if you think sixty to seventy
thousand thoughts in one day and we do
and ninety percent of those thoughts are
the same thoughts as the day before and
you believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny your
life's not going to change very much
because the same thought leads to the
same choice the same choice leads to the
same behavior the same behavior creates
the same experience and the same
experience produces the same emotion and
so then
the act of becoming conscious of this
process to to begin to become more aware
of how you think how you act and how you
feel it's called metacognition and so
then
why is that important because the more
conscious
you become of those unconscious states
of mind and body
the less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought
is not going to slip by your awareness
unchecked
because you're
it means to know thyself and the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so as you become familiar with the
thoughts the behaviors and the emotions
of the old self you're retiring that old
self as you fire and wire new thoughts
and condition the body into a new
emotional state if you do that enough
times it'll begin to become familiar to
you so
it's so important
just like a garden if you're planting a
garden you've got to get rid of the
weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you got to pull them out the
rocks that sift to the top that are like
our emotional blocks they have to be
removed the soil has to be tenderized
and broken down we have to we have to
make room to plant a new garden so
primarily we learn the most about
ourselves and others when we're
uncomfortable because the moment you
move into that uncomfortable state
normally a program jumps in when that
program jumps in it's because a person
doesn't want to be in the present moment
and engage it consciously
so when you teach people how to do that
with a meditative process
it turns out that when they're in their
life
they're less likely to emotionally react
they're less likely to be so rigid and
believe the thoughts they were thinking
they're more aware of when they go
unconscious back into a habit and that
is what starts the process of change
and so we have to unlearn before we
relearn we have to break the habit of
the old self before we reinvent the new
self we have to prune synaptic
connections and sprout new connections
we have to unfire and unwire and re-fire
and rewire we have to unmemorize
emotions that are stored in the body
then recondition the body to a new mind
into a new motion like deprogram and
reprogram that's the act and it's a
two-step process the stronger the
emotion you feel from some event in your
life be it a betrayal or a trauma or
whatever the more altered you feel
inside of you the more you pay attention
to the cause outside of you so the brain
takes a snapshot
it freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true i just want
to understand the maybe the larger the
event in terms of its emotion to you the
stronger of a hold it has over you yeah
well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life
and it catches all of the brain's
attention so now they think
neurologically within the circuits of
the past experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on for
extended periods of time
so that the event produces a chemical
change and the body needs to return back
to homeostasis or balance but if it
can't then the elongation of that
emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say ed what's
wrong with you i'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and i'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry i don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago i'm
having one long emotional reaction i'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves
by living in the past and so then you
say to them well tell me the story now
the latest research on memory says that
50
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have wow just to reaffirm that they
can't change right wow
so then what's the significance of this
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy period yes so then
the stronger the emotion that you have
to some problem or condition or person
in your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
away to that person right because
they're capturing your attention so then
there's an energetic connection to every
person everything everything in your
past present reality has your energy
connected to it so now
this is the significance when a person
really decides to be defined by a vision
of the future instead of the memory of
the past the hardest part about it is
all of a sudden becoming conscious and
not making the same unconscious choice
so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lowered the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back three
types of stress physical chemical and
emotional physical stress trauma
accidents injuries false
chemical stress toxins pollutants heavy
metals blood sugar levels viruses
bacterias mold and then there's
emotional stress which has everything to
do with raising kids and
and second mortgages and single
parenting and time and
and all of those different elements
knock the brain and body out of balance
and the emotional component has always
been the challenging one for most people
because you could be in a constant state
of fear
and consciously or unconsciously
it doesn't matter the food you eat it
won't matter the type of exercise you do
if you're living in fear the body is not
in any state for growth and repair so we
have to face this one important element
and
and this is a time now where we have to
be greater than our fear if you're
sitting down and you start thinking
about
some future worst case scenario that
you're conjuring up in your mind
and you begin to feel the emotion of
that event
your body doesn't know the difference
between the event that's taking place in
your world our world and what you're
creating by emotion or thought alone
so most people then
they're they're constantly reaffirming
their emotional states so when it comes
time to give up that emotion
they can say i really want to do it but
really the body is stronger than the
mind because it's been conditioned that
way so
the servant now has become the master
and the person all of a sudden
once they step into that unknown they'd
rather feel guilt in suffering because
at least they can predict it being the
unknown
is a scary place for most people because
the unknown is uncertain people say to
me well i can't predict my future
i'm in the unknown and i always say the
best way to predict your future is to
create it not from the known but from
the unknown what thoughts do you want to
fire and wire in your brain
what behaviors do you want to
demonstrate in one day the act of
rehearsing them mentally closing your
eyes and rehearsing the action
the rehearsing the reaction of what you
want or
the action of what you want by closing
your eyes and mentally rehearsing some
action if you're truly present the brain
does not know the difference between
what you're imaging and what you're
experiencing in 3d world so then you
begin to install the neurological
hardware in your brain to look like the
event that's already occurred now your
brain is no longer a record of the past
now it's a map to the future and if you
keep doing it priming it that way
the hardware becomes a software program
and who knows you just may start acting
like a happy person i'm not the type of
guy who sits in my house meditating 24
hours a day and expect things to come to
me i'm a pragmatist i'm a practical
person i'm going to take value and
information i'm going to apply it and
see if i can gain more value from it so
the message is not to sit and meditate
and just receive universal love and do
nothing else
because
my message is to not disengage in life
but to fully engage in life that's my
message think of your autonomic nervous
system
as the automatic nervous system and i've
been saying for years that autonomic is
synonymous with automatic and it's that
part of our
systems part of our nervous system that
functions behind the scenes of our
awareness and it regulates body
temperature and and hormones and blood
supply and blood sugar levels uh in it
and it happens without any uh
of our conscious mind so in the
autonomic nervous system there are two
branches so one is the sympathetic
nervous system
and its job is for protection
from threats and dangers in our outer
environment and think of the sympathetic
nervous system as the gas pedal and when
there's a danger to the gross anatomy of
the body
by something in our outer world that we
can perceive with our senses
this system is switched on automatically
and once it turns on
there's a host of physiological
functions
that begin to happen automatically
and when that occurs we're mobilizing
all of the body's energy
all of the body's resources
for that threat or that danger to deal
with it and and when it's switched on
we don't go half in we go all the way in
because we have to make sure that the
body is going to survive
survive in a threat or a danger in the
outer environment and and when there's a
release of all those adrenal hormones uh
we're tapping the body's resources
and we're mobilizing all of its energy
and pupils dilate salivary juices shut
off respiratory rate increases heart
rate increases
blood is sent to the extremities glucose
is mobilized the immune system dials up
and then it dials down and all of these
systems switching on and turning on is
to be able to allow the body to adapt to
some threat in the outer world and
uh that is the gas pedal and the
sympathetic nervous system or the
fight-or-flight nervous system
causes us to really do just a few things
to run from the danger
to fight
and stay or to freeze and hide
and those are the primary choices that
we have created in evolution
and so
when the sympathetic nervous system is
switched on
and we as we've been saying for very
long for a very long time
uh
the short-term effect of the hormones of
stress the body can adapt and return
back to balance and it switches on
the other nervous system that branch of
the autonomic nervous system called the
parasympathetic nervous system
and think of that nervous system as the
break
or the clutch
this is where the body conserves energy
this is where utilizes nutrients and and
transports chemicals to cells and
metabolism goes up and and this is a
time for growth this is a time for
repair this is a time for restoration
and there's a delicate balance between
the sympathetic nervous system and the
parasympathetic nervous system
and so then when you're feeling
a constant fear
when you're feeling constant anger or
aggression when you're feeling constant
pain and suffering and you're living by
the hormones of stress
what was once very adaptive is now very
maladaptive because if stress is
knocking your brain and body out of
balance and the stress response is what
the body does to return it back to order
if we're living in constant fear then we
are tapping the body's vital resources
and there's no energy
for growth repair restoration there's no
energy for long-term building projects
crossing that river of change from the
old self to the new self there's a
neurological a biological chemical
hormonal a genetic death of the old self
but if you teach people there's
something on the other side they won't
give up on themselves they'll keep going
so there's enough evidence to encourage
people and you can't tell me you're too
old to do this work you can't tell me
you're too sick to do this work you
can't tell me you had a turbulent past
or or that you're too overweight or too
underweight or too out of shape or
you can't even tell me that you've never
meditated before in fact some of our
greatest
scans are people who just have never
meditated before that are not trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not fifty percent in not sixty
percent and we do a week-long event we
got a thousand people or fifteen hundred
people and they are all in and that when
they start getting beyond themselves
that first day or second day once they
start getting beyond themselves
and that magic starts to happen then i
have no idea i can't predict
what's going to happen next and it's
usually pretty pretty exciting could you
speak about the
neurophysiology of forgiveness
sure
think about
frozen circuits
frozen circuits
are hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain
freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no
and the more we remember the event the
more we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no yes and it you
keep doing it enough times it's no
longer conscious that you're holding a
grudge it's no longer conscious
that
you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted everybody
is that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality you're not seeing it the way it
is you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person
that's the lens that we're perceiving
reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception
triggers the emotion in the network and
you're back in your past and you're
acting like you were when it happened
are you with me still
and so then the person says i'm not that
person you say oh no i know i just had
this event in my past and i'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this
we all do it
it's just how do we overcome it
so then
you're sitting
and doing the work and you're you're
moving energy up those centers
you're releasing
the life force into your brain
you are
blessing those centers and taking a
scoop and moving it all the way up and
releasing it all the way up into the
field you're opening the channel
your unfolding is nobody no one no thing
nowhere in no time and the identity and
the personality is gone which energy is
going to move scott was going to follow
the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion
when you feel true true kindness and
care it's hard to hold a grudge
are you with me still yes
so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still
so then from a quantum perspective you
are actually
as a creator of reality
holding yourself hostage
because of that person
and you are holding them hostage because
of that experience and you have an
energetic bond that's connecting you to
them and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that
energetic agreement is
are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone
it's because there's been a strong
change
in your emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start lowering the
volume to that emotion and the body
starts liberating energy and you're
calling your energy back to you because
the lower the volume of the emotion the
less you're going to pay attention to
that person there comes a moment where
there's a snap there's a release the
energy is broken
and once it's broken now all of a sudden
you free yourself
and you free them
and
this has happened to me in my life the
people show up 10 years later
completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because
they had transformed and i let them go
so then
forgiveness
from a quantum perspective and a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them
that's all it is
and when you start getting happy with
yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this for the
grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still now
once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing 1300 to 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body
the body start getting a lift of energy
once it makes it's here now you're gonna
see that track sending in energy to the
brain the heart acts as an amplifier to
boost the brain
are you with me still
so then once the energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin and you
feel more loved then you feel the grudge
so then you think
why would i want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness
you don't have to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation
and oxytocin then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites as fear and
it lowers the volume to fear and anxiety
it shuts the lights out for aggression
and anger and hostility and it cools the
circuits off for suffering and pain and
the only thing you can feel is a love
for life
and that's when you're free now the
practice
of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it
takes a long time and a lot of work
and then you forgive and then you're
like i don't want to forgive him
[Music]
halfway forgive him
and just never really authentic
forgiveness
do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and
she had severe
severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
she came to our event
in
in
tacoma washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
oneness
and the
and that frequency had a message for her
and it said
and she was an incredible bliss when
this happened
i sent four angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her terrors
that was the end
of her night she couldn't have a
relationship she couldn't she could not
live with anybody she was
she was isolated
one moment the divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download
not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy moved right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for
now she's healed she's healthy she's
happy and she's on with a new life she's
born again my mother would love this
she's born again in the same life
reborn in the same life didn't pass to a
birth canal for it
she just was born again
in the same life she got a new lease in
one instant
that energy was carrying a message
and it made its way all the way into the
body and the bliss and the joy and the
gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried with
made total sense to her
she's free one instant
to me that's true forgiveness
that's the divine having its way with
you most people are waiting for their
life the change yes so they can feel
gratitude to feel abundance to feel
whole you know that's the old model of
cause and effect you know so if you're
living with emptiness you're living with
lack you're living with pain
most people have been conditioned that
something out there has to take away
this emptiness or feeling inside of them
but
if you believe that you're creating your
life and you're living by lack well lack
is going to create abundance right so
so then it makes sense then that you
don't really actually
create wealth you generate wealth you
generate abundance so the moment you
start teaching your body emotionally
what that future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest well your body
is the unconscious mind believes it's
living in that future in the present
moment now it's the scientific fact that
it's the environment that signals the
gene okay
the end product from an experience in
the environment is an emotion
so when you begin to embrace an elevated
emotion you're beginning to signal the
gene ahead of the environment what's the
importance of that well genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and the function of
your body and the expression of proteins
is the expression of life so by you
creating an elevated emotion and
teaching your body what that future will
feel like before it's made manifest your
body's starting to live in that future
reality in the present moment now here's
the key
if you were able to become familiar with
gratitude become familiar with wholeness
become familiar with abundance to become
familiar with freedom and you're able to
generate those chemicals every single
day
more than likely you would be walking
around feeling like your future has
already happened then you would no
longer be looking for it to happen you
would already feel like it has happened
now what is the importance of that well
you're literally becoming somebody else
so you're leaving your lack you're
leaving your guilt you're leaving your
emptiness behind your personality
literally yet is made up of how you
think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life
your personal reality you got to change
your personality and here we go again
you got to start becoming conscious of
your unconscious thoughts you got to
start noticing how you act how you speak
you got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new choice a new choice should
lead to a new behavior a new behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right i believe in human possibility
human potential and i think that one of
our biggest
limiting beliefs is the belief have how
limited we really are
and so my interest is to give people
the science to begin to understand how
powerful they really are and i think
that science really is the language that
does that really well and in the new
sciences like quantum physics and
neuroplasticity neuroscience
neuroendocrinology you know
psychoneuroimmunology the mind-body
connection epigenetics all of those
sciences point the finger at
possibilities so i want to create a
language for people
from a philosophical or theoretical
standpoint for them to begin to
understand what's possible
but then i want to be able to have those
people begin to wire that information in
their brain completely because learning
is making new connections right in the
brain
but remembering is maintaining and
sustaining those connections and it's so
much easier
to lose our vision than to remember it
right so then we have to begin to
hardwire the brain or install the
neurological hardware
in preparation for an experience so the
more people understand what they're
doing and why
then the how gets easier so i wanna then
set up the conditions in an environment
in a in a in a workshop where people can
begin to
apply or personalize what they learn so
that they can have an experience and
experience then further enriches the
brain but the prize of an experience is
an emotion and once you start feeling
unlimited once you start feeling
abundant once you start feeling worthy
now you're teaching your body chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood so
knowledge is for the mind and
experiences for the body and people
begin to embody the truth of that
philosophy now if they can repeat it
over and over again it will become
innate in them and become natural second
nature become easily begin to master
that philosophy so i want people to
begin to understand that
thoughts are very powerful feelings
drive our thoughts
and that they can begin to create a
better life for themselves once they
understand some of these principles 15
20 years ago
everybody wanted to stay in the
philosophical realm nobody wanted to do
anything with it but this is this is the
time in history where it's not enough to
know this is a time in history to know
how because information is so available
right i mean you don't need a doctor you
don't need a priest you don't need a
rabbi you don't need a governor you
don't need a teacher to gain information
you need an authority any longer because
of technology we have access to
information well information creates
awareness
and awareness is consciousness and you
can't have consciousness without energy
so people are beginning to wake up with
a greater level of awareness of what's
possible so
15 years ago 20 years ago 10 years ago i
walked out and there was always a little
resistance
but now people are coming because they
want to
actually experience the truth of it so
that makes my job easier because i can
just walk out and just fire away because
people are prepared they're informed
they're ready so anything that's not
consistent with that energy or that
level of awareness
those paradigms are beginning to break
down whether it's education whether it's
religion whether it's politics economics
the environment the medical model
everything is collapsing because people
are informed
so
i love that idea because when people
show up and they say
well listen
i understand that i have a health
condition i understand that it's taken
me
10 years
of being unhappy 10 years of living in
stress 10 years of living in fear that's
actually begin to signal or select and
instruct the gene that creates the
disease
well it may take me some time then
to unlearn that process to break that
conditioning process so there's a
practical understanding now
but
something amazing has happened i mean
we've spent
over 10 years doing very advanced
scientific studies we've done over 8 500
brain scans we've measured
so many
thousands of hearts because if you're
going to create a new future it requires
a clear intention and elevated emotion
well let's train our people how to
create really really high level brain
coherence and really really really
self-regulating heart coherence why
because if you're going to believe in
that future that you're creating with
all of your heart it better be opened
and activated and you better know how to
do that and you better understand the
science of what happens we've measured
gene regulation 7500 different gene
regulations we know you can change your
gene expression in four days we've
measured it you're not you're not doomed
by your genes you're your own genetic
engineer that
that um you can lengthen your life and
we've seen telomeres actually lengthens
60 days of meditation that you you add
days your life you're changing your
genetic future that you can strengthen
your immune system by thought alone
that's
that's that's the evidence from the
scientific perspective and people
love the evidence because they start to
see that's possible you're not going to
find that in a pharmaceutical commercial
you're not going to find that out there
in the world you got to really be hungry
and look for it so then that sets the
stage for the person to come and want to
have that experience there may not be so
quick to say hey i want to heal my body
right away they may say
i need to get my brain heart coherent
first and i got to begin to put my
effort into learning how to do this like
learning any skill
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there